il ne se passe pas une journée sans que
le flou ne s'épaississent autour du plan
de déconfinement ce qu'on sait c'est que
la date clé du 11 mai a été retenue par
le président de la république c'est pour
cela que le confinement le plus strict
doit encore se poursuivre jusqu'au lundi
11 mai on a appris depuis du directeur
général de la santé lui même qu'il n'y
aurais je cite pas de déconfinement si
le confinement n'est pas réussi voilà de
quoi doucher nos espoirs de liberté
retrouvée surtout qu'on ne connaît pas
vraiment les conditions de réussite
d'une telle mesure
autre contradiction entre l'elysée et
jérôme salomon jeudi dernier lorsque ce
dernier s'est exprimé lors d'une
audition à l'assemblée qu'il faudra
éviter et ça c'était l'inquiétude que je
partage avec vous c'est ce sont les
transports inter régionaux et les
échanges de population entre des zones
massivement touché des zones que toucher
c'est comme ça qu'on on va réactiver la
circulation du virus notamment vis-à-vis
de deux zones très peu touché les
déplacements inter régionaux seront donc
interdits après le 11 mai eh bien non
explique l'elysée un peu plus tard le
palais présidentiel fait savoir lors
d'un briefing à des journalistes je cite
qu'il n'y aura aucun problème pour se
déplacer d'une région à l'autre
l'exécutif obligé de rectifier le tire
une nouvelle fois lorsque jean michel
blanquer affirme le 15 avril dernier que
l'école est obligatoire y compris après
le 11 mai le ministre de l'éducation
nationale repris de volée puisque
l'elysée a annoncé ce jeudi que la
reprise des cours se fera sur la base du
volontariat
jean michel blanquer de nouveau rattrapé
par la patrouille lorsqu'il explique là
aussi à l'assemblée les modalités du
retour à l'école
cela signifierait que nous ferions
entrée à partir du de la semaine du 11
mai et réalité ce ne serait pas le monde
mais lui-même ce qu'il y aurait une pré
rentrée des professeurs de l'école
primaire
mais au cours des jours suivants nous
ferions rentrée les classes de grande
section de cp et de cm2 ensuite on
aurait l'enseignement secondaire en
semaine 2 c'est-à-dire la semaine qui
commence
et avec le co le collège pour lesquelles
ce serait la classe de 6ème et la classe
de troisième une sortie que n'a
visiblement pas apprécié l'entourage du
premier ministre selon cet article du
monde
c'est un énorme pataquès souffle une
source gouvernementale blanc caire a
fait ces annonces alors que les
arbitrages n'avait pas été validé avec
matignon et qu'on lui avait demandé de
ne pas communiquer sur ce sujet alors
comment interpréter ces ratés dans la
communication de l'exécutif
le nombre de personnes habilités à
s'exprimer pendant cette crise pourrait
expliquer cette confusion à vouloir
occuper le terrain médiatique en
multipliant les prises de parole des uns
et des autres on s'expose inévitablement
à des couacs de ce genre comme le
souligne maxime ait kaki docteur en
sciences politiques dans cette tribune à
force de multiplier ses apparitions
l'entourage présidentiel donne
l'impression de courir derrière
l'information au lieu d'apparaître comme
celui qui en est le principal pourvoyeur
autant de faux pas qui laisse peu à peu
transparaître la mécanique manipulatoire
de la communication de crise et de voir
en elle le palliatif d'une gestion de
crise
erratique un temps chef de guerre
emmanuel macron semble avoir fait
évoluer son attitude multipliant
allocutions et déplacement au risque
peut-être de parler pour ne rien dire
parfois car même si chacune de ses
prises de parole est suivie par un
nombre record de français
les enquêtes d'opinion sur la
communication présidentielle sont
sévères face à une défiance grandissante
le président a tout intérêt à corriger
le tir lors du déconfinement pour tenter
de faire oublier les errements du début
de la crise